good afternoon I'm Lois Frankel from
Florida and I want to thank everybody
who for being here today
speaker Pelosi all my colleagues and we
have a special guest Michelle Williams
who has a very interesting story for you
so today is equal pay day when women's
when women's earnings finally catch up
for what men earned in 2018 today we are
catching up and I think don't we all
agree that we women shouldn't have to
work 15 months to be paid what men
receiving 12 thank you for acknowledging
that it is it's very sad and troubling
that even in 2019 on average a woman
makes 80 cents to every dollar a man
makes and it's even worse for women of
color and if the current trend continues
women will have to wait 40 years for
equal pay but not if we have our say
right okay and the african-american
women will have to wait a hundred years
Hispanic women will have to wait
205 years something's wrong with that
and look it's not just the stress of
here and now paying the bills because
over 40 year career a typical woman
loses more than $400,000 because of the
wage gap and that's why so many older
women are in poverty we know that many
households women are the main bread
winner said listening women go to work
for the same reason men goes to work
take care of families pay rent retiree
dignity and live happy and full lives
with their families and now the
Democrats with are for the people agenda
we've set our sights on tackling issues
that keep women from reaching their full
economic potential like access to
affordable health care quality childcare
and so forth and raising the minimum
wage and promoting family
family-friendly workplaces like
family leave policies last week we
continued the drumbeat by passing the
Paycheck Fairness Act
and today over a hundred members are
introducing a resolution a resolution to
mark equal pay day because when women
succeed and now I turn the podium over
to I call her the godmother on Pay
Equity rosa DeLauro from community thank
you so much Lois wonderful to be here
today and I'm so delighted to be able to
join with all of my colleagues in the
Democratic Women's Caucus so I'm going
to say commemorate equal pay day is just
a day on which the average woman's
earnings finally catch up to what the
average man made last year every year
I'm going to be very upfront with you I
hope we never have to recognize this day
again because we will have finally
achieved pay equity and we are on our
way and it is so great today to have the
talented award-winning Michelle Williams
she demonstrates something that we all
know that these disparities exist at all
levels of education and occupation even
at the very top wage discrimination
takes place not just on the soccer field
or the silver screen but in the
boardroom the factory floor in countless
other workplaces across this country
that is why we are fighting for equal
pay for all women simple concept men and
women in the same job deserved the same
pay last week Paycheck Fairness pass in
the floor of the House of
Representatives overwhelming and in fact
yes bipartisan 242 to 187 now it needs
to pass the Senate and make it to the
President's desk it's my understanding
that what time is it now to 40 to 45 the
Senate is going to take it up and let's
just see where it goes and that would
just
focus our attention on the Senate
paycheck toughen remedies in the Equal
Pay Act of 1963 giving working women the
opportunity to fight wage discrimination
receive the Paycheck that they have
earned it protects employees from being
fired for sharing their salary
information with coworkers establishes a
grant program to provide salary
negotiation training for girls and women
it ensures that employers are not
reliant on wage history when they hire
an employee it is about giving women the
power to gain economic security for
themselves and for their families so
important so important now when
Americans are stuck in jobs that do not
pay them enough to live on this is our
biggest economic challenge it's not a
partisan issue the wage gap affects
women and families regardless of party
affiliation it is though a matter of
right and wrong and simple fairness one
half of the work paper force is paid as
much for the same job as the other half
so we have the opportunity to make good
on the promise that presidents I might
add from both parties of Maine the issue
and the environment have collided equal
pay is now at the center of our public
discourse women are motivated they're
activated they're watching and we are
listening and we are acting with the
passage of Paycheck again it's time now
for the Senate to do the same it is now
a distinct pleasure to introduce to you
the Speaker of the House a close friend
fierce ally devoted supporter of
Paycheck Fairness she made it clear from
day one that this was an absolute
priority so an honor that she's here
today and proud to fight alongside her
for women's economic agenda
[Applause]
thank you very much Rosa for your kind
introduction for your tremendous
leadership on behalf of America's
families this is a bad equal pay for
equal work and the impact that it has on
America's families and you have been as
they're distinguished here Lois Frankel
said the godmother of so much and
especially the Paycheck Fairness Act I
just want to tell you this story because
earlier that was mentioned when women's
to keep succeed America succeeds and
when we were on that bus tour and we
went to roses district this story I
think demonstrates the an array of
issues on behalf of working families
that Rosa has been involved in we're
there and a woman came to testify and
she said I'm not going to tell you my
story which is about a single mom
overcame obstacles now as a school bus
driver so I'm going to tell you about
the stories that I had the people that I
see every day every day I pull up to the
curb and I can see it coming there'll be
a mom there with tears in her eyes and I
know what she's going to do she's going
to put a sick child on the bus
for these reasons first of all she can't
afford to take a day off because her pay
is low and if she takes a day or two or
three off she may not have a job she has
no paid sick leave so she cannot resort
to that and she certainly cannot afford
child care that was the story of so many
women in our country the idea that that
Rosa has had and she passed this when we
had the majority before we couldn't get
60 votes in the Senate but nonetheless
hopefully public opinion will weigh in
with the same
now in that regard I want to acknowledge
so many of the groups are here from ACLU
to Williams YWCA Leadership Council on
civil and human rights you know das
American Association mercy women senator
from American Progress justice for
migrant women momsRising National
Domestic Workers Alliance National
Partnership for women and families
National Women's Law Center I named some
they're more my name some because
without the outside mobilization it is
impossible to make the difference just
with inside maneuvering so we thank all
of you that women would start earning
money her 2018 2018 wages and salaries
etc so it is an important day for us but
the important day was last week when we
during Women's History Month was under
roses leadership we were able to pass
the legislation as I mentioned it's not
just this issue that Rosa has taken lead
on but all the full complement of issues
that are about work balancing work and
family and as Lois Frankel mentioned
this isn't just about losing four
hundred thousand dollars as serious that
is to a family it's about the pension
the retirement of women as well and
affects them assault in our our later
years so it is it's so really very very
important so I thank Rosa for her
leadership in that in that regard and it
is it's it's pretty exciting but nothing
tells the story more eloquently than the
story the personal story and to have a
person with us today who has had the
generosity of spirit to publicly tell
her story and in a way that is so
compelling and raises the awareness in
the public of the issue she star of
stage and screen a fighter for therapy
which she was discriminated against in
her own respected arena
so when star power weighs in it really
does have a way of attracting much more
attention we think we're in the traction
business but really when somebody who
isn't really in the attraction business
calls attention to one of the challenges
that all women many women face and
before I bring her on I just want to pay
tribute to our friends in labor because
not know nothing has done more no
institution from the bus stop to the
workplace in so many different ways
women will benefit from again the
generosity of spirit of our very special
guests and I want to give a nice capital
welcome to Michelle Williams it's a real
change for me to have my own story to
tell and not somebody else's so thank
you speaker Pelosi for the invitation to
join you this afternoon and to observe
this important day equal pay day I'm
grateful to you and to congresswoman
DeLauro and to all of the Democratic
women of Congress who have been
steadfast in your pursuit of securing
equal rights for women and for all
people in our country so I'm here to
tell you my story and it's the kind of
story that I would normally resist the
morality tale with a happy ending
or maybe I should call it a happy
beginning because that's really why I'm
here there won't be satisfaction for me
until I can exhaust my efforts ensuring
that all women experience the elevation
of their self-worth and it's connection
to the elevation in their market worth
that I have become so fortunate to
finally know after 25 years in my chosen
profession
in late 2017 the news broke that I'd
been paid less than $1,000 compared to
the 1.5 million dollars that my male
counterpart had received for the exact
same amount of work and guess what no
one cared this came as no surprise to me
it simply reinforced my life learned
belief that equality was not an
inalienable right and that women would
always be working just as hard for less
money while shouldering more
responsibilities in their homes and if
it was like this for me a white woman in
a glamorized industry how were my
sisters suffering across their
professions
when the news passed as quickly as it
had broken i sat paralyzed and feelings
of futility I've been a working actress
since the age of 12 and I've taken every
challenge as an opportunity I've been
accredited within my industry at the
highest levels and that still did not
translate into equal and fair
compensation months passed and the
actress Jessica Chastain with whom I had
in fact once played sisters asked my
permission to take my story to her
Twitter she recognized three things
first injustice second timing it was a
different moment there was a new
clearing in the air that thanks to the
mounting me to movement and the work of
Toronto Burke and the courage of so many
women coming forward to tell their
stories and third was her platform in
her power
Jessica's audience was much wider than
mine and she wasn't afraid to pick up a
megaphone and be heard and heard she was
there was an uproar and a public shaming
within my industry that resulted in a 2
million dollar donation to the times up
Legal Defense Fund a group of fellow
actresses and I invited activists as our
dates to the 2018 Golden Globes where I
was a nominee and rather than talk about
our dresses we voiced solidarity for the
oppressed and violated women in our
industry and across all industries we
were all a part of the newly forming
times of organization and seeking to
roll out change in our industry as a
rallying cry for others when I went back
to work after these events I could tell
that
workplace was shifting rather than being
grasped too tightly and hugged for too
long as a morning greeting my hand was
shaken and I was looked squarely in the
eye and I was welcomed to my Monday
morning I realized this is actually what
it feels like to be on the inside to be
one of the boys in this space respect
and safety are out in the open they are
not just found in the shadows and the
corners and on the job I just completed
two weeks ago let me tell you something
I was paid equally with my male co-star
and now we're at the heart of why I
traveled here to talk to you the
firsthand experience that I hope
decision-makers can hear from this
platform that I've been given when a
person or a group of people acknowledge
your worth you seek to meet that worth
because they see you as you want to be
seen which is as of value and when you
feel you are valued you express your
value and where does that value go it
goes to your work it goes to your fellow
colleagues it goes to your employer it
benefits your entire organization it
strengthens the parts that advance the
whole this is the kind of human math
that it only takes a heart to add up
imagine a workplace where women don't
have to spend extra or any energy
fighting for fair pay or defending their
rights but can instead focus that energy
on the fullest expression of the task at
hand and enjoy both the pride that
brings and the product of that pride
which is fair and equal compensation for
every woman the ball is now in the
Senate's Court women families in our
country will win if members of the US
Senate
take the decisive action that is
required to pass the Paycheck Fairness
this is the next critical moment please
don't let it pass us by
Thank You Michelle it's powerful when a
woman tells her story I'm congresswoman
Brenda Lawrence and I am one of the
co-chairs of the Women's Caucus this
year marks 56 years since the passage of
the Equal Pay Day Act in 1963 women work
hard to continuously break down barriers
and fight against workplace
discrimination in 2019 we have brought
our seat by shirley Chisholm told us and
advised us if they don't have a seat at
the table bring a folding chair so we
brought our seat to the table and we're
making our voices heard we no longer
accept being paid less than our male
counterparts earning approximately 80
cents a dollar
86 for every dollar a man earned and
women of color it should be significant
to note earn even less relative to the
typical white male 60 cents for a dollar
that for typical black woman and 55
percent for two for every dollar man
makes for the Hispanic woman in the
african-american community black women
make up 10% of the low-wage workforce or
jobs that typically pay less than $11 an
hour while they make up about 6.2
percent of the overall workforce this
ladies and gentlemen is also an economic
discussion the current lack of pay
equality is shifting the economy and
propelling women and families into
poverty should women become when they
become properly compensated the poverty
rate will be cut in half falling from 8
percent to 3 point 8 percent among
working women that is a reason for us to
act if you have no compassion for the
fact that there's a inequality you care
about this economy this is a reason
there are combined economic challenges
for women dealing with pay such as
inflexible work schedules lack of basic
benefits such as paid sick leave and
family leave workplace discrimination
harassment and unfair treatment today we
let the working women across this
country know that the women of Congress
we have your back our voices have power
and we are demanding quality
20:19 as some have said is truly the
year of the women of the woman and I'm
so proud to bring one of the amazing new
members of Congress I do not use that
word fresh man because she's not a man
but one of the new members of Congress
my colleague representative Escobar to
speak I want to thank leader Pelosi for
her incredible leadership her incredible
female leadership and the strength and
the power that she brings to this caucus
every single day to congressmen the
congresswoman DeLauro thank you thank
you thank you for your relentless
leadership on this issue for your
determination to make sure that this
never fell to the backburner and that
you have you will consistently remind
this caucus this Congress this country
that we have a long way to go and I'm so
grateful for that and yes thank you
to Michelle Williams thank you for those
beautiful words thank you for sharing
such a personal story for lending your
fame and your voice to helping uplift
other women we're so grateful and to my
sisters standing behind me my sisters
who were on the House floor to all of
the women of this country we deserve
better it is incredible that it is the
year 2019 and we are still talking about
issues related to women being
second-class citizens because my friends
indeed that's what this is about
when we look at whose health care is
most threatened when we look at whose
livelihoods are most threatened and when
we look at who shoulders the vast
majority of the burden in this country
it is the woman we expect women to raise
our kids to clean our homes to plan for
the future to be the center of the
family to go to work to earn a living
all things that we do with grace and and
we do with every inch of our being and
we provide dignity in all that we do to
deserve equal pay is a bare minimum a
bare minimum of what we should be
fighting for in this country and it is
shameful that today we are still
fighting that fight but there is so much
hope in this Congress in this body of
women in the leadership that women have
provided and in the way that women this
year have said enough and so together
this is but the first step that we will
be taking as we continue to fight for
stronger values that make America the
great country that she is a country that
is led by women thank you
and I want to introduce a fantastic
leader an incredible voice and my
co-chair for the Democratic Women's
Caucus my dear friend Deb Holland from
New Mexico thank you thank you all so
much for taking the time to be here this
afternoon the fact that we're standing
here for months in two days into the air
the amount of time it takes a woman to
earn what her male counterpart earned
last year tells us that there's still a
problem I'll tell you something else
it's worse for women of color
we'll be marking latina and Native
American equal pay day in June that's
six months into the year there are
people who will deny that this is an
issue we should be addressing but let me
tell you what it means to a family it
means the difference between several
months rent each year or some trips to
the grocery store each month can you
imagine what the impact is for a single
mom without any other income stream I
know what it's like because I have a
single mom when you get to the checkout
stand and have to figure out which items
that you have to put back because you
don't have enough in your account
back that women earn less money for the
same jobs as men it's about fairness and
we're taking action the Paycheck
Fairness Act is needed and I'm proud it
passed on the House floor last week if
we can get this done it will mean the
world for women and their children who
are working hard to make ends meet thank
you all so much and I hand it back to my
colleague and I am here to say thank you
all for being here today let's keep our
eyes on the Senate and Michelle Williams
thank you again for joining us thank you
[Applause]